here to break it all down for us is
chris schneider kimberly van agan and
scott jorgensen thank you guys so much
for being here thank you for having us
so all right i uh i need to work off
i've had donuts champagne i'm just on a
roll leading up to this but you guys
have come up with some really fun ideas
and real quick just tell us a little bit
about ufc fit i've actually been out
there before and you guys offer a lot of
fun things we do we do um so it's it's
definitely a newer club in this in the
valley
you know the concept of what we do is a
little bit different than what i think a
lot of traditional clubs are used to the
beautiful thing is because it's ufc we
have the ability to offer you know mma
style of training and coaching but we
put a lot of emphasis on three major
aspects well obviously with the mma
conditioning training
the recovery center we have services
like cryotherapy
normantech hydro massage and then we
train youth programs as early as age six
wow so it's a huge opportunity to start
you know children off at a young age to
start getting a little bit more active
in the you know in in fitness all right
well so you guys obviously know what
you're doing and i trust you so let's
get right to it you know leading up to
valentine's day we all want to look our
best so why don't we show off some fun
couple workout ideas absolutely and you
know the beautiful thing about exercise
is you don't need a lot of equipment to
do it especially when you have a partner
right so
so scotty and kimberly here are going to
demonstrate just a few things that you
could typically do
at home or at the gym
just to get the blood pump in a little
bit so let's do it we're going to start
off with something very simple we're
going to go into a squat 1-2 combination
so uh guys go ahead and start here we go
we're gonna go three two one begin
and then we're gonna go there you go
stay in sequence because again the the
couples that train together stay
together right
and then we can also go into uh partner
push-ups so we're gonna go into some
partner push-ups right now um basically
what they're doing is just holding each
other accountable as they go down
together and then switch hands there we
go and then coming down here i say easy
enough like i could do that but you know
what maybe it's possible you guys are
making me think that i'm sure you can so
and then again when you're when you're
focusing on exercise you want to focus a
lot on core strength and stability so
one of the exercises that we're going to
do right now is just partner leg lifts
so then when you have somebody to anchor
you down you have some stability so
scott go ahead and get on the ground
kim's going to be his anchor because
she's a strong anchor yes she is
all right so he's going to come up to
about parallel and she's going to give
him some resistance by pushing down on
his legs oh i can feel the abs burning
there you go absolutely
and then of course from here what you
want to do a lot of times is you want to
really get your heart rate going so we
tend to do some traditional hit
exercises so they're going to perform
right now what we call a jack push climb
it's kind of our our um
version of a burpee okay so go ahead and
guys we're going to go three jack push
climbs on my account here we go in three
two one go
up down
push up mountain climber in the middle
back up jack there you go there you go
now we're finishing up real quick just
let people know where they can check you
out at ufc so we have two locations here
in the valley uh we have centennial
right off of the 95 and anne road and
then of course we have our silverado
location right off of silverado ranch
and maryland parkway so
again two two locations in the valley
and hopefully a few more to come all
right awesome thank you guys so much and
now we can all get our sweat on mercedes